[Musik]
herzliche sie sind fonds an senioren
haben mich deswegen hier an den rand der
berliner schlucht eingeladen um mir
einige besonderheiten hier zu zeigen
mitunter eben diese aber das ja ganz
bekannt dafür dass es ein heiliger baum
ist und interessant wenn es um beseelte
natur geht was hat denn dieser baum so
spezielles an sich ja die eibe ist der
warum der wirklich außerhalb des
gewöhnlichen steht es ist ein baum der
extrem vital ist und praktisch
unsterblich wenn man in biologischen
sieht und versteht wieder wächst und er
wurde als solcher kanton der wirklich
uns als bindeglied zwischen der
physischen welt und auch scheinlich
derweil dahinter genommen unsichtbaren
welt für diese alten völker und so dass
völker keltische völker geben die ihren
namen von eigentum und die avon ist das
eigene volk und die eu wies die einen
krieger oder dann hat das auch die limo
witzes gegeben die ulmen krieger die
einen kriegen das waren die kriege dank
der kraft der liebe und diese eben waren
im zentrum ihrer
religion oder ihres lebens und waren
dann auch immer verbunden mit diesen
alten stein setzungen die sogar vor geld
sparen also mit diesem egalité
deswegen stehen die haben dann auch bei
alten kultstätten oder genau das hat sie
dann geschützt diese diese besondere
stellung auch bei diesen und golfplätzen
diese verehrung hat sich an geschätzt
worden
bäume fällen bei der christianisierung
und was würden sie sagen was ist das
ganz besondere dieses baumes das eben
eher als heilig angeschaut wurde und
nicht an andere hier sind man schon
wieder aus sich selbst wieder heraus
wächst und so das ist vegetative kraft
und ganz alte bäume haben eventuell
einen so dicken stand es ja immer wieder
macht wird und dann können wir darüber
wie wurzeln im eigenen körper angelegt
werden und sogar will kann der baum
eigentlich über jahrtausende sich immer
wieder erneut kein schöneres bild für
für ewiges leben oder leben und tod die
sich verschmelzen und zusammen wirken
hier sieht man effektive die sogar eine
unglaublicher vitalität kraft hat weil
es oft hat ja einen sehr guten einfluss
auf den menschen in japan gibt es das
bald werden haben sie auch schon zur
spezielle natur erfahrungen gemacht
ja ich bin natürlich schon als kind die
die bäume geklettert und dann die wälder
durchwandert und dann später immer mehr
man ja genau das gehört dazu aber auch
barfuß im waldgebiet sehr wichtig da
kommt elektrische
kraft eigentlich in den körper und auch
übernachten im alter freigegeben sind
nicht frei himmel unter den baumkronen
hinter macht dann zieht plötzlich
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bei der halbe haben wir von heiligen
stätten gesprochen jetzt liegt wie ein
riesiger findling haben der baum und
dieser stein eine verbindung ja immer
auch dieser stein der ist von den
gletschern heran gebracht worden und
steht jetzt auf dem fels grund das war
ein sogenannter wackerstein der
eigentlich früher einmal sich bewegen
ließ und verbindung mit den bäumen hat
das ganz bestimmt nicht weit von hier
hat einfach sehr viel solche schalen
das war für ihre opfer gabel bestimmt
ist ja wirklich auch bei heiligen
stätten dann bei heiligen stätten genau
diese ganze region ist eigentlich schon
gekannt und diese steine mit ihrem
riesigen gewicht auf dieser unterlage
entwickeln auch eine form von energie
sogenannte bier zu elektrizität weil das
gewicht auf gewicht auf unterlage
erzeugten druck direkt ich auch eine art
strom freigibt und reagieren die bäume
darauf und die bäume regel ganz
bestimmte hoffmann kann elektronen an
die beim ersetzen und merke wie ich sie
eigentlich bio elektrische ströme habe
und sie läuten auch elektrizität in den
brunnen also die steine und die bäume
haben auch ähnliche funktionen in diesem
sinn
sie schreiben in ihrem buch man könne
bäume auch als die menschen das
pflanzenreich sehen die uns helfen den
herzschlag der welt zu spüren
für mich klingt das eigentlich erst mal
ziemlich esoterisch worin gleichen sich
der mensch und pflanze so trügerisch ist
es sicher nicht weil wenn man die bäume
wissenschaftlich untersucht dann merkt
man schon ein paar parallelen zum
menschen
das vegetative wachstum bevor es blüht
ist ein sehr langes und erst nach 30
jahren sichern machen die bäume blüten
und früchte und samen und dann der die
standhaftigkeit mit diesem aufrechten
wachstum mit dieser vertikal itt ist
auch mehr hat es ein symbol ist ja
wahrscheinlich überlebensstrategien die
auch mit ihm um stärke zu tun haben sie
eine ganze mikrochirurgische flora
duschen und diese jahrhunderte immer sie
wachsen
es ist sehr ähnlich wie bei uns menschen
dass uns auch so alt werden lässt was
ist denn die grenze zwischen mensch und
natur
das werden sie sagen also die grenze
zwischen mensch und natur sichtbar
tierreich pflanzenreich autohof das
heißt sich selbst zustands aufbauen mit
sondern nicht und hätte rot-rot pflanzen
brauchen zum selber erleben können
da ist ein gegensatz aber es gibt ein
paar ähnlichkeiten jetzt der puls das
thema puls alles was lebt pulsiert und
die bäume 2 genutzt aus auf der feinsten
weise unsere forschung hat zeigen können
dass sogar der baumstamm pulsiert und
wenn man den sondereffekt ein bisschen
weg nimmt abschirmt dann pulsiert der
baum im rhythmus des bundes der und
gezeiten und wie misst man dass das in
ganz genaue messanlagen und man
hundertstel millimeter stammdurchmesser
variationen erfassen kann
und dann passieren die knospen der bäume
es pulsiert
der elektrische strom in den stämmen
einsetzen kann und was man jetzt weiß
die erde selber hat auch strömen
elektrische ströme und und bewegungen
geologische und man spricht vom puls der
erde das ist die so genannte schumann
frequenz zwischen 7 und 8 herz also eine
frequenz mit 87 schlägen pro sekunde das
ist sehr langsam natürliche vorgänge
was kann der mensch von der natur von
bäumen von pflanzen lernen eben erstens
dass das alles pulsiert und das
eigentlich alles sind zusammenhang steht
mit dem größten umkreis diese
verbindungen der bäume sind nicht nur
mit geld sondern auch mit dem kosmischen
geschehen also mit dem astronomischen
geschehen die die gezeiten habe ich
erwähnt oder die position des mondes im
sternen hintergrund als tanz wurde
wissenschaftlich dann validiert oder
festgestellt wie es die frühere und
kultur und traditionsgemäß immer gesagt
haben sie sprechen damit auch etwas an
weil sie sagen ja dass der wald ein
organismus sei und die bäume quasi
sozusagen einzelne organe dieses
organismus was geschieht denn konkret
mit dem wald bin ich jetzt ja einen baum
fällen genau weil der organismus durch
ist sehr wichtig das richtig zu
verstehen
von außen gesehen ist ein weil die mal
geschlossen hat da wirklich immer eine
hülle eine schutzhülle
das ist das wichtigste organ eines
organismus auch für die einzelzelle ist
die zellmembran das wichtigste organ und
bestimmte zellen brauchen gar keinen
zellkern aber einnehmen bauern gibt es
also bald mit schutzhülle und er besteht
aus bei mir natürlich die waldsaum
pflanzen sind dann ist ein anderer
auch bäume und der hauptwahl und jetzt
ein baum wird somit zum organ des waldes
der ein ganzes bildet und innenraum und
angst und sind dann
sehr unterschiedlich und jetzt für den
förster ein baum im wald entnehmen ist
nicht einfach ein individuum baumfällen
das ist ein teil des waldes wegnehmen
damit wieder mehr licht in der woche in
den wald kommt aber indem man das ganze
doch respektiert und als organismus
nicht stört sondern einzel weise aus
herausnehmen
aber viel weiß man denn welche bäume man
nehmen kann und wo man also wo man den
organismus nicht stellt das ist sind
fünf jahre ausbildung als forstingenieur
wo man dann wirklich warnt berndt und
welche baumarten brauchen wie viel licht
wie wenig und wie viel kann man auf aus
dem wald heraus nehmen die nachhaltige
nutzung menü das ist alles mit jedes
first jetzt wenn sie das war erzählen
geht das alles zusammenhängt dieser
organismus dann wundere ich mich hatten
ein wald ein bewusstsein
also je mehr man an die natur heran
kommt umso mehr merkt man das ist nicht
einfach eine eine grüne kulisse es das
sind sie stehe jetzt einmal so gesagt
die einen eigenen funktionieren haben
und wenn wir jetzt feststellen dass bei
klimatischen störungen plötzlich der
laut wegen das waren das plötzlich
herabgesetzt wird die ausdrucksfähigkeit
des waldes plötzlich nicht mehr ganz da
ist dann kann man sich schon sagen der
wald hat vielleicht auch etwas mehr als
nur eine ansammlung von bäumen und sich
und in früheren kulturen und man schon
von waldgeistern gesprochen das war in
kabul aber ist da
bewusstsein dabei da bin ich gar nicht
abgeneigt
da soll sie prozesse zu nehmen und so
ein organismus wären wald ist auch durch
sie das nicht ein bewusstsein haben man
weiß wie lange wir welche zeiträume ist
uns so etwas sich immer mit dem
frisieren aufrechterhalten kann
können denn bäume kommunizieren können
wir das verstehen und können wir in
diese kommunikation mit eintreten so wie
bei michael kollegen kommunizieren das
wissen wir jetzt genau wo die wurzeln
über gas ausdünstungen mit dem kosmos
fachkräfte die wir noch nicht ganz genau
verstehen aber wir merken das phänomen
bio elektrisch also es gibt elektrische
impulse die auf die barrieren wirken das
wasser ist ja immer als substanz
dazwischen sehr wichtig also wenn wir
kommunizieren untereinander
das ist klar wenn ja ziehe die
angefressen wird von einer kultur und
die lupe meldet es den nachbarn die auch
ist dann dass die konsistenz und die die
die qualität des lagers sender und damit
ja und die lupe weiter fressen geht ich
kann denn der mensch da eintreten kann
der mensch das verstehen was die
kommunizieren die bäume also kann der
mensch verstehen auch hier kann man sich
fragen wenn man wissen zurückgeht und
langsam immer mehr respekt hat zu den
früheren kulturen
diese alten kulturen bei uns fahren ist
die gelten
in amerika die indianerinnen afrika und
so weiter diese ur völker hatten eine
art kommunikation direkt mit der
pflanzenwelt die ihnen irgendwie
pflanzen geheimnisse mitteilte für mich
ist das natürlich vollständig offen
aber je mehr ich forschungen mache in
diese richtungen
umso mehr habe ich respekt von diesen
erfahrungen und stelle mir schon mal vor
dass auch einmal wissenschaftlich
verstanden wird und würden sie sagen
dass die natur beseelt ist wenn wessels
sein bedeutet dass sich etwas ausdrückt
und emotionen von sich gibt dann kann
man schon ganz klar sagen es war ein
wald als organismus hat eine ganze menge
von von emotionen die idee bekannt
gegeben werden
denken wir nur an die vogelwelt und die
insektenwelt bevor man sieht das ist ein
einzelfall ist mein einzel insekt das
sind eigentlich ausdrucksweisen des
waldes auf einer höheren ebene gesehen
und beseelt hat man den wald immer
verstanden in früheren kulturen und je
mehr ich mit solchen sachen
wissenschaftlich um gehe darum so mehr
merke ich dass diese alten kulturen
reelle wahrnehmungen hatten und so habe
ich das immer mehr als mögliche prozesse
was mich schon immer fasziniert hat
jetzt sich gleichmäßige form von tanz
appen aber auch von blättern und in
ihrem buch schreiben sehr über diese
spiralförmig kite als ein prinzip des
lebens können sie das erklären
ja das ist effektiv ein ganz schönes
gesetz soll der bau eines ganzen seine
früheren zapfen ist extrem geometrisch
genau bekannt also jede gruppe gehört
rechtsorientierten spiralen und einer
linksorientierten spirale und die summe
der spiralen rechts oder links
orientiert ist immer ungleich
asymmetrisch und wenn man alle sounds
opfer nimmt fichtenzapfen führen zapfen
lehrschen zapfen dann hat man eine
bestimmte anzahl von spiralen die sich
immer wieder befindet 358 13 21 und
jetzt hier haben wir acht und fünf zb
dann ist das verhältnis von 2 nach einer
unserer folgenden zahlen immer der
goldene schnitt der berühmte und dieses
spiel haben sie auch lebensprinzip genau
der spiral prinzip findet man überall wo
leben vorhanden ist also stecken
natürlich am menschlichen körper
weiter wie die haare ein wirbel bild und
das herz ist auch spiralig auf welt
gebaut die muskelfasern und auch das
wasser zeigt dieser spiralen die vortex
bildungen des wassers links oder rechts
und das ist wirklich ein prinzip das
durchstehen ist bei entspannungsmusik im
wellness zb hört man ja vogelgezwitscher
oder was er geräusche und im wald ist es
alles gewalt reagieren denn bäume auch
auf geräusche das was weiß man jetzt
auch genau die vögel singen nicht nur um
territorium zu schützen oder abzugrenzen
jetzt weiß man dass das eine wirksamkeit
hat auf die aminosäuren synthese potenz
interesse und man hat sogar bestimmte
sequenzen erkannt das ist sicher schon
die träume der schamanin saskia
mittendorf die mich erwartet ganz
herzlichen dank natürlicher für ihre